welcome back to CBS mornings and the
latest on the midterm elections that so
far have done very little to shift the
balance of power in Washington now we
should emphasize there are still a lot
of races to be decided with that said
let's bring in our top White House
Correspondents Ed O'Keefe and Nancy
Cortes two political Pros that belong in
the White House hall of fame um to break
this all down Nancy it's a better night
than expected for the Democrats you know
what are you hearing from the White
House oh big change of mood from the
White House in the past 24 hours
yesterday they were trying to
pre-explain why it wouldn't be a big
deal if they lost a bunch of seats now
they're saying wait maybe we didn't lose
a bunch of seats maybe we just lost a
handful of seats they're saying that
they feel excitement mixed with some
validation because they manage they
think to Buck a historic Trend they
didn't lose dozens of seats the way
previous presidents have and we were
calling out the fact that the president
didn't go everywhere or the places he
went seemed a little off given where we
thought the Battlegrounds were but
people all the different places though
people didn't want them and the ones
again another one struggling but where
he did go they held on Wow all right and
and you know it's it's a signal that and
John fetterman especially there was
somebody who completely embraced the
Biden Legacy the Biden White House said
come on down and help me out he came
former president Obama came and he eked
it out a bunch of races he went to in
New Mexico in California and Illinois
and other places like that and we all
went why are you going there yeah Kathy
hokel here in New York twice he came out
to help her and she pulled it off so the
lesson is don't bet against Joe no bet
against politically the guy always finds
a way it seems and that's what the White
House is preparing privately maybe he'll
say it publicly at some point it'll be
interesting he knows what he's supposed
to say of course we're expecting to hear
from him at some point today but let the
jokes begin about the Red Wave I've
heard it called you know the red
sprinkler I've heard it's called the red
splash the red puddle needless to say
there was there was not this Red Wave
not this red tsunami so did you see
anything earlier in the evening that
might have indicated that this is how
out would turn out yeah they were they
were iron races in Rhode Island New
Hampshire Connecticut Indiana Virginia
they said look we're going to win those
early it's going to be the start of it
none of the materials they got one race
in Virginia where Donald Trump had won
uh pretty easily back in in 2020
otherwise the Democrats prevailed in all
those other races and they were parts of
the country where they were anticipating
being able to take districts that had
been Democratic for decades or for like
100 years down in Texas for example and
it just did materialize Democrats saying
look midterm voting patterns in these
parts of the country at least stayed the
same abortion clearly was a factor that
you saw them playing that up and there
will probably be some indication that
the president's focus in the closing
days on issues like democracy reminding
people what had happened on January 6
may have also helped close the gap with
Independence so Nancy former president
Trump as you know wanted to play King
maker in these midterm elections I saw a
lot of prominent Republicans tweeting
yesterday that this is primarily on
Trump's shoulders the candidates that he
endorsed did not do as good as well as
expected so what does that mean for him
looming large over the Republican party
some notable high-profile stumbles by
candidates that were not favored by the
Republican establishment but were
anointed by former president Trump I'm
talking about Dr mehmed Oz in
Pennsylvania Blake Masters who's
trailing right now in Arizona Herschel
Walker failing to clear 50 percent in
Georgia that state now goes to a runoff
Republicans argue this is another reason
to turn the page from former president
Trump but the reality is he's Hill still
has so much power with the base and
frankly he's going to call it a victory
no matter what and one notable thing
with those Republican gubernatorial
candidates especially who never
committed to certifying uh 2020 election
results or they say they wouldn't say
that they would have right all of them
lost the only one we're waiting on is
Carrie Lake who of course was one of the
most vociferous deniers of the 2020
election results again a signal yeah
it's voters are saying hold on a second
like you're not in line with actual
factual results and that should not be a
tough state for a republican to win
after last night you think he's going to
run next week the guy says he's running
all right no he said he has a big
announcement are you talking about
Donald Trump we're talking about Joe
Biden I'm talking about I'm talking
about I'm talking about Trump well Trump
says he's got a big announcement next
week and big big announcement we'll see
when the big announcement comes whether
because we've been hearing for the last
several months that he was several weeks
away from saying something so let's see
if he makes good next week Nancy Ed
thank you so much that White House Hall
of Fame would be by the vending machine
no it's by the microwave